this is the neighborhood of LGR arbor in
central Tripoli it's known for its
high-end shops and cafes the streets are
calm but talk to people here and you
were reminded that Libya is at war I
can't quote Sayed without feeling
nervous
I'm afraid unless there's a lot of
people around only then do I feel
comfortable enough to walk on the
streets the fact of the people is
completely different depending on where
in Tripoli you are it's called for the
people here but the problem is for the
people near the front lines but we are
all affected by the war it's
psychological because you constantly
know your country's at war when you
drive south from el jurado things start
to change the traffic begins to thin
there's less people on the streets and
is evidence of shells landing in
civilian neighborhoods this cafe is
around a kilometer from the front line a
few people still come to drink coffee
here but the atmosphere is tense
abdullah hussein lives close by the
bombing is random we live on our nerves
any moment a bomber rocket can hit it's
especially bad at night we are too
afraid to sleep we have to be ready to
run immediately people now even know the
types of bombs by their sounds and this
is supposed to be a ceasefire we
continue to drive south pass this
unmanned checkpoint to a neighborhood
where safe for the fighters there are no
signs of life there is no evidence of a
ceasefire here it took us 20 minutes to
drive here from the peaceful streets of
el jurado where life on the surface at
least seemed normal but here in the
neighborhood of salahuddin virtually
every building has been either damaged
or completely destroyed it's getting
late in the day here now and commanders
on the ground are telling us that they
are nervous because this is the time
where the majority of the shelling
starts this area was populated by
thousands of people and they have all
left they have all fled the fighting it
show
you just how much of a contrast there is
between this neighborhood and the
neighborhood of Jarama
that we were in earlier this is a war of
attrition it seems and despite the
ceasefire the fighting goes on chants
trafford al jazeera southern Tripoli